in this seminar on faith and
globalization we're interested in
exploring how faith and globalization
processes intersect with one another now
faith remains to be a powerful force in
the world today
indeed the number of adherents to
various world tradition religious
traditions is growing today and not just
growing but also various faith
traditions are increasingly inserting
themselves into public domain and then
the question is how does faith as
engaged for it intersect with
globalization processes what is the
nature first of the religious resurgence
what is their extent of that resurgence
and then how in particular faith is
inserting them so that itself in
globalization processes we want to look
at particular cases cases from various
spheres of life in which that becomes
evident and we're interested in
conditions under which faith can in a
salutary way inserts itself and
contribute to human flourishing so
primary questions that we are engagement
is can faith be part of globalization
processes or must it by the very nature
of the faith itself retreat in a ghetto
and if it gets engaged in the world
today in particular in globalization
processes how can that engagement be
constructive how can it be in such a way
that it shapes to the good those
powerful forces that globalization
processes are and in particular I think
significant issue is whether the faith
which by its nature defines the identity
of people and its adherents whether it
can not just define and give meaning to
the lives of people but also pull
diverse people's together so that they
can work in cooperative ways of course
the course of this sort will be covering
diverse topics and approaching it from
the vantage point of different religions
but it has limitations
and we will limit ourselves to three
religions Christianity Islam and
Buddhism and maybe making side looks at
other religions as well and also we
cannot survey the whole of the globe we
will concentrate on North America Europe
and Asia but this is only a first in the
series of courses that will be offered
at Yale of the same nature and in the
fall of 2009 and 2010 we will repeat and
this time hopefully broaden the scope
include more topics include other
religions which we have left unincluded
as well as ask different sets of
questions that emerge in the context of
the intersection between faith and
globalization processes